[Musique]
les impromptus c'est un petit on va dire
association de petits moments comme
comme leurs noms l'indiquent culturelles
tout disséminés ou au sein de la ville
en fait ils ont pour origine la période
colis d'où on avait dû interrompre
toutes nos festivités classique et on a
souhaité quand même mais avec un public
plutôt réduit puisqu'on n'était pas
autorisé à rassembler les foules
séduire un petit peu le public en leur
rappelant mais attendez la culture n'est
pas perdue elle revient bien vers vous
là plusieurs catégories d'événements il
peut y avoir des déambulations par
exemple des petits orchestres
alors battu cada ou sans fard un peu
classique si vous voulez qu'ils vont
aller se balader dans un petit quartier
vous avez aussi des performances
artistiques un petit peu plus structuré
avec par exemple des pique niques
musicaux proposés par le conservatoire
les mercredis du 1er et 15 juin vous
avez aussi un spectacle de danse qui va
se produire dans le quartier du val
hibou
souvent les les points de départ sont
aux rendez vous sont les centres
commerciaux et puis après l'idée c'est
d'aller déambuler un petit peu dans le
quartier avoisinant donc on aura la
bretèche l on aura centre commercial de
l'egypte le quartier des gâtines mais
également sainte apolline tout le monde
ne pourra pas tout voir mais au moins
chaque quartier aura un petit événement
sympa soient musicales soit circassiens
[Musique]